he was Colombia's most famous artist
said by many to be Latin America's
answer to Picasso
Fernando otero's paintings and
sculptures were renowned around the
world his style shows subject in
exaggerated form displaying every day of
life with color and a unique irony
born in the Colombian city of Medellin
in 1932 potato as a youth studied to
become a bull fighter
But ultimately follow his passion for
art
he was kicked out of secondary school
for his drawings of naked people but he
persevered and as an adult began to
develop a following potato created a
movement known as voterismo that was
also committed to denouncing abuse on
War
he painted about the conflict in
Colombia but also the abuse is committed
by the United States in the Abu grave
prison during the war in Iraq
the entire world rejected these actions
especially since the United States
presents itself as the country of
compassion and civilization these
Barbers acts seemed like something from
the Middle Ages
potato created a collection of 50
paintings that he says came from his
heart
in Colombia violence is a totally
different phenomenon it's rather the
result of ignorance and a lack of
education but torture carried out by the
wealthiest and possibly the most
civilized country in the world is
definitely not the same thing potato was
91 years old when he died
in Colombia the president said he was
the painter of the country's virtues and
its errors
potato sculptures and paintings are
located in different cities around the
world a reminder of an artist who dared
show the world in his own unique way
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera